it was a period in my life where you
know I've got in trouble and I was
hanging around the wrong people then I
found football that's when my you know
my life took a bad turn
and now I'm here whoops those born in
Nigeria went over to I'm stabbed to live
with my mom you know she wanted us to
have a bad life so she sent us over to
UK things just didn't work out the way
she planned I ended up in foster care
you know I bounced around from home to
home it was a period in my life where
you know I've got in trouble when I was
just hanging around the wrong people
that I found football that's when my you
know my life took a bad turn and no I'm
here I didn't take off sport until 22 I
found American football for a friend
he saw my size and he thought that would
be a best fit for me
I knew nothing kabayan ago before the
London Warriors you know coming from
London not having the exposure not
coming from a a fake background
been a long process didn't happen
overnight I've had some a lot of wars
that I've had to overcome you know when
I was in Dallas I think I got released
like six times then I went to Kansas
City and they were released I went to
Atlanta and then I got released not took
a year out this is nothing compared to
some of the things I've been for
initially when I went to Dallas my first
position was a tyrant which required me
to run routes and and block people
didn't catch the ball it was just too
much it was a minnow over though that
was talking like it was sounded like it
was talking a different language so they
deem that I was bearable for me to give
me a better opportunity to put me on
defense and you know it worked out it
was easier to learn you know it was less
thinking our first-ever
NFL in season game you know been working
very hard for that just to get on that
field and just get on the floor alone
was an achievement it was amazing and my
performance or the blur honestly can't
remember half of the earth and that's
how watch it but everything that
followed afterwards the coach and
players being happy
get the game book and the NFC Player of
the Week you know when I starts just
amazing
just focus I just I just stay focusing
on the fact that I'm in a different
country by myself for a reason a lot of
people have you know taking time are
their lives that invested in me to get
me into that position and give me the
opportunity honestly it's just one game
and I'm grateful that I'm here I'm
grateful that I had a really good game
but astounded I hold myself to just
doesn't have plates at one game I want
to cause a really strong career just
keep being a player that affects games
for me this is the opportunity that I
have but there's so many people that
don't have the love for football but
they just need opportunity whatever is
that you're you you love or whatever it
is that you want just go for it
there's gonna be times where you know
people gonna say no or you're gonna fail
to surround yourselves with good people
trust the process have a plan and just
believe and just keep keep grinding and
now that kind of got me where I am right
now
and I'm gonna keep that same process on
the key that same equation and you know
I'm gonna go places and hopefully you
guys will too
[Music]